One, two, three.
Ever since the late 19th century somewhere around 1886-88,...
...Rutgers college students had a tradition of planting ivy at graduation...
...of inscribing their class year on the side of Kirkpatrick Chapel...
...and also smashing clay pipes on a cannon.
What this was supposed to signify is a putting away of the dissipations of youth.
Students as recently as the 1970s, I'm told,...
...would smoke these clay pipes at the cannon...
...and then proceed to smash them against the cannon as they got in line for graduation.
And so today, we're attempting to recreate that here at the last Rutgers college commencement.
The 1,700 or so students gathered here today,...
...started here at Rutgers University as members of the Rutgers college class.
And they were very clear that even after our reorganization...
...of the undergraduate colleges into the school of arts and sciences,...
...these students really very much wanted their diplomas to reflect the fact that they were admitted to Rutgers College.
The group of undergraduates, not seniors, they're not graduates,...
...have formed an organization called the Rutgers University Historical Society...
...and they asked if we could please bring this tradition back in a big way for this last graduation.